you could like see that we've been
running out of space like if you look at
technology like in the early 2000s audio
everything was like surround sound you
got to get a surround sound system this
Dolby Digital 500 everybody's like whoa
500 was it always 500 they're like we
don't know but it's
loud like bring your boys over your boys
are like wow this is loud this louder
than your wife you know and it was the
early 2000s so we hated the wife you
know
I don't know why I
was everything was surround sound and
now audio is just noise
cancellation they're like you don't want
to hear what's going on out
there it's messed up and the walls are
thin and and you don't really have space
for four speakers and a
subwoofer the only space you can afford
is in your inner
canal